hey everyone is cereth register nurse
sorry and calm and today we're going to
talk about walkers and as always when
you get done watching this youtube video
you can access the free quiz i will test
you on this assistive device so let's
get started when you're studying walkers
for your exams there are some things you
want to remember you want to remember
the proper fit what are those
characteristics that the Walker actually
fits your patient how to walk with the
Walker so the gait and how the patient
should get up and set down in a chair so
first let's talk about proper fit how do
you know that this Walker actually fits
your patient well before a patient even
uses a walker for the first time it has
to be adjusted and on most Walker's
they're adjusted down at the bottom you
have to adjust each leg there's four of
those legs so you've adjusted the Walker
now what do you look for these are
things you want to remember for your
exams well have the patient hold onto
the hand grips while they're standing
with the Walker and you're going to look
at that elbow there should be about a
fifteen to thirty degree bend in the
elbows also when the patient holds their
arms down at their side their wrist
crease should line up with those hand
grips those two things really tell you
that this Walker fits this patient the
next thing you want to know about is the
gait how does your patient actually walk
with the Walker and this is something
that you really want to pay attention to
for exams so you want to make sure that
you're paying attention to what's moving
first is that the Walker is at the weak
side or the strong side and how that
order goes so before a patient actually
uses a walker for those first couple
times you want to make sure that you
have applied a gait belt to their waist
for safety also you want to stand on the
patient's weak side in case they start
to stumble or fall you want to be there
and you want to tell the patient before
they start ambulating with their Walker
that they don't want to stare down at
their feet while they're doing it even
though that just seems like something
natural you want to do that can actually
mess them up and cause them to fall they
want to look straight ahead just like if
they were walking normally and the
starting position
how do they start out walking with their
Walker well they want to make sure that
the back tips of the Walker match up
with the middle of their foot now let's
talk about how you actually ambulate
with a walker to ambulate with the
Walker first the patient's going to get
in position and hold on to the handgrips
of the Walker first they will lift and
move the Walker forward and then make
sure all four points of the Walker are
touching the ground then they will move
the weakside put weight on the hands via
the hand grips and then move the strong
side again they will lift the Walker
move it forward make sure all four
points are on the ground then they will
move the weak side put weight on the
handgrips
and then move the strong side
you
to sit down in a chair a patient is
going to take their Walker hold on to
the hand grips and slowly back up to the
chair until they fill the chair with the
back of their legs then they're going to
slightly extend that weak leg out and
take their hands and position them
behind them and bin their strong leg and
feel for the chairs armrests and then
set down to get up from the chair what
the patient's going to do is of course
make sure the Walker is out in front of
them they're going to lean forward out
of the chair make sure their hands are
on the hand rest and slightly extend
that weak leg out then they are going to
put weight on their hands by pushing up
on the armrests of the chair and with
their strong leg and putting their hands
on the hand grip of the Walker then they
are ready to ambulate
and again to do that they will lift the
Walker make sure all points are on the
floor move that weak leg put weight on
the handgrips and then move the strong
side thank you so much for watching
don't forget to take the free quiz and
to subscribe to our channel for more
videos